Thanks this is a perfect setup so uh
let's see so I'm gonna talk a little bit
about what it takes to make to make the
blockchain kind of more use more usable
for business I'm a cartographer so to me
everything looks like a crypto problem
and so let me tell you a little bit
about computer beautiful problems that
come up from from these blockchain
technologies I can't I can't give a I
can't give a talk on cryptocurrencies
without talking about the the huge
increase season in prices over the last
year I actually think this is a bad
thing for the research community because
it's causing over hype in the area and
it's causing the research community to
miss to miss out on the beautiful open
problems here this is an area that like
I said suffers from a lot of over hype
but there are really new scientific
problems to think about here so again
I'm a technologist so I'm interested in
the in the in the in the computer
science aspects of these problems you
know so these these blockchains they
generates you know questions about new
consensus protocols new programming
languages for smart contracts so ways in
which we can write smart contracts in
which we can verify that the contracts
do what they're supposed to do there
have been many famous mistakes of smart
contracts that end up not doing what
they're supposed to and millions of
dollar tens of millions of dollars are
getting lost as a result the Dow is a
typical example of that there's new
cryptography that's needed for these
block chains and finally there's a lots
of mechanism design questions I just
throw one out there so we talked about
miners and and how they operate I think
you guys need to understand and miners
today they're not like people sitting in
their homes and mining that doesn't work
anymore
because of the expense of what it takes
to mine so miners are actually large
organisations today they have that have
thousands if not tens of thousands of
machines doing the mining that's one
type of miner the other type of miner is
a mining pool where you know a hundred
thousand people kind of come together
saying well each donate cycles to mining
so that we get the the block the block
reward and then the question is how do
you distribute the block rewards across
the people who contribute to the pool
that's actually a really nice mechanism
mechanism design question so might be
interesting for for folks here to think
about yeah so even though my machine
participated but
not generate the winning the winning
solution I should still be eligible for
some of the reward and the question is
how to distribute those rewards so
anyhow so in this talk I'm gonna focus
of course on the crypto aspects and i
hope i'll you know convey that there's
lots to do here as well but this area as
i say even though it suffers from over
hype this area is gonna be with us now
for a long time this is a wonderful
scientific research area and if they do
institutions there are new people
working on blockchains
you're really missing out because this
is this is this area is gonna be with us
for you know for a long time
alright so let's continue so i wanted to
say a few words so thanks for the set up
explaining how Bitcoin works I wanted to
say a few words about Bitcoin although
everything that I'm gonna say is much
more generic and applies to almost all
cryptocurrencies out there so I'll pick
on Bitcoin is the example so of course
the Bitcoin blockchain is a chain of
blocks yeah so you can see this is the
these are the block headers that live in
each in each block what lives in the
block header is basically a hash of the
previous block this is what causes the
chain there's also a set of transactions
the transactions themselves are
organized in a tree for a certain reason
which I won't get into here then there's
a nonce which is related to the proof of
work and then there's a timestamp as to
when the this block was actually mined
the timestamp is also used for updating
the the hardness the proof of work
hardness as as was mentioned before okay
so that's what the blockchain looks like
when we zoom in on transactions I just
wanted to emphasize how that how the
actual model works so there's no no
accounts and no account balances in
Bitcoin the way money is managed is
through what are called unspent
transaction outputs so every transaction
has a bunch of inputs and a bunch of
outputs whenever a transaction is
created what is created is what's called
an unspent transaction output at UT
Excel so this would be UT Excel number
one and UT excel number two the UT so
basically has a value associated with it
which is how much money was transferred
to this address and same similarly here
how much money was transferred to this
address so how many coins were
transferred to this address and then a
subsequent transaction all
does is it points to a previously
unspent transaction output as part of
its inputs and then the process repeats
we create new new uth cells the point of
view TXO is it can only be spent once so
once a UT XO has been spent it can no
longer be spent again and you might as
well forget that it ever existed and in
fact most miners will delete the ut
EXO's once they've been spent so the
only thing that the miners have to keep
in memory is what's called the UT EXO
set which is the set of all unspent
transactions on the blockchain
everything else everything that's been
spent is erased and does not need to be
kept online is that clear so that's the
UT EXO model so they're actually no
balances or accounts or addresses or
accounts it's all managed by UT EXO's
that bind values to addresses okay so
that's the UT EXO model the problem with
this is this this model is completely
unfit for business yeah it's complete
mismatch for business and so I just
listed an example transaction here so
what you see in this transaction is the
following you can see that these two
addresses these two Bitcoin addresses
each contribute this amount of Bitcoin
and they go to these two addresses and
the output is you know this address got
two bitcoins and this address got 0.01
Bitcoin in an edition the fee was 0.01
79 Bitcoin that goes to the minor the
problem with this is when you look at it
you realize wait a minute these
addresses are completely public on the
blockchain so I can tell exactly who is
paying who so to you this might seem a
little bizarre because this address is
just a cryptographic hash so how do I
bind this to a physical entity but it
turns out actually there's a lot of work
that shows that in fact it's very easy
to bind these addresses to actual
physical entities just to give you an
idea for how this works you know if you
pay me in Bitcoin let's say my address
is the output address and then later on
I go and spend my Bitcoin at a coffee
shop and the Stanford campus boom boom
you just learned that whoever was paid
here is someone who probably works at
Stanford you know the next thing is you
know I might end up you know maybe I
spend some some money
Bitcoin and buying coffee on the
Brooklyn Brewery campus today and then
you surmise oh probably he's attending
assignments workshop today and very
quickly you can kind of nail down
exactly who this person is and there's
been a lot of work on this on basically
unmasking who these identities are and
binding them to to physical addresses in
fact there's a bunch of companies that
do this and so you know you should not
assume this is what's called
pseudonymous addresses they look random
and in fact they're not too difficult to
bind to real world real world addresses
okay so that's one fact that it's easy
to tell who's paying who the bigger
issue is that in fact the amounts are
completely public on the blockchain now
if you think about that that doesn't
make any sense for businesses this is
just immediately prevents businesses
from using the blockchain for payment
just think about if everyone knew how
much was being was being paid to who
that means you know if Stanford paid my
salary in Bitcoin anyone can look on the
blockchain and see exactly what my
salary is that makes no sense at all
maybe in Berkeley it makes sense public
university if Stanford does that does
not make sense at all right more
generally in industry this would not be
acceptable but even more generally if
you want to manage supply chain using
the blockchain right if you can look on
the blockchain you see exactly how much
Ford pays its tires pays its supplier
for tires you know that would violate
basically all the rules of doing
business between customers and suppliers
so this is kind of just a mismatch
fundamentally the blockchain is a
mismatch for business yeah
you can but in fact it's not that
difficult to link all these identities
together yeah so like I said there's a
lot I'm not gonna talk about privacy on
the blockchain I can tell you there's
like by now there are dozens of papers
and companies that all they do all day
long is just analyze the blockchain and
bind identities to say all these
addresses actually belong to one
identity and then you can match the
identity to a physical entity based on
what where the addresses are yeah it's
just it's not that hard there are lots
of algorithms it's actually actually
pretty interesting graph algorithms but
with enough graph algorithms you can
actually do it okay there's a problem
clear so Pierre and Pierre public and
more importantly the values that are
being transferred are public as well so
there's a system called Z cash and
Manero that actually tries to hide who
the payor and payee are in this talk I'm
actually not going to talk about hiding
the payor and payee I'm more worried
about hiding the value which is
essential again for businesses so the
payer a payee will continue to be public
I just want to hide what values are
being paid so you'll know that I'm a
stand for an employee and Stanford pays
me a salary you just wouldn't know what
the salary is okay so let's talk about
how we do that
so the idea actually this is an idea
that dates back to 2016
due to Greg Maxwell so the idea is to
basically change how the blockchain
operates so instead of writing values in
the blockchain instead of writing these
actual numbers on the blockchain what
we're instead gonna do is we're gonna
write what are called commitments okay
so what are commitments
well so I can't give a talk without
doing a little bit of math so what are
commitments commitments you can think of
it as taking a number and sticking it in
an envelope and then putting the
envelope on the blockchain so I'm bound
to that number but nobody can see what
that number is it's in the envelope and
mathematically the way this works is
what I do is I kind of give you this
this this number here which is
essentially the value is embedded in
this exponent and it's being blinded by
some random number multiplied this
multiplied in so there overall this
number is reveals nothing about the
value V but I cannot change what the
value of E is once it commits to it okay
so that's what's called a cryptographic
commitment and that's what we're gonna
put in the blockchain okay so now if you
look at the transaction you have no idea
how much was transferred or you see are
just
these cryptographic hashes which mean
absolutely nothing nothing to you the
transaction fee by the way continues to
be public because the minor needs to
collect it yeah so we're not hiding
transaction fees either okay good so now
that's a fine idea but now you remediate
Li run into a big problem
yeah so you think about doing that the
problem now is if you look at the block
at the blockchain now how do you verify
the track that the transaction is valid
if you don't see the amounts how do you
know the transaction is valid so what
does it mean for a transaction to be
valid well fundamentally what we'd like
to make sure is that the sum of the
inputs is equal to the sum of the
outputs plus the fee right that's kind
of a fundamental equation of a validity
for a transaction but now you can't do
that you can't verify that it's true so
we just lost the whole point of a
blockchain right the whole point of a
blockchain is anyone can look it can
look at it and verify that everything is
about and now we can't do that anymore
so what do we do yeah so how do we
verify this equation and the answer is
you know crypto magic yeah so the crypto
magic is what anybody no no no no not
that magic slightly different crypto
magic so the crypto magic here is zero
knowledge proof okay so it's a
homomorphic brothers have a morphix
brother yeah so our sister rather so
zero knowledge proof yeah so what are we
gonna do essentially when we create a
transaction what book will additionally
create a zero knowledge proof that says
that this actual disc equality actually
holds it holds and it turns out that's
actually not very difficult to do yeah
and because of the way these commitments
work it's actually quite easy this is a
linear equation and it's quite quite
easy to produce your knowledge proofs
for a linear equation I should say zero
knowledge proof means that I could
convince you that the fact that is true
without revealing the underlying values
so you'll be convinced that star holds
but you wouldn't know what the input
values and output values are okay so
that's that's number one however it is
and there's another requirement which we
almost ignore and the other requirement
is that all these values these inputs
and output values all have to be
positive in fact they all have to be
positive in the interval 0 to 2 to the
50 to minus 1 this is basically the unit
of spending in Bitcoin yeah so
numbers have to be positive think about
that if the numbers were not necessary
to society we're not necessarily
positive we would run immediately into a
problem right if one of these outputs
happen to be negative then here's what I
would do I would create a transaction
that takes say five bitcoins as inputs
and then outputs one you 2x over 7 and
the other you T Excel will be worth - -
yeah so star is satisfied however now I
have a UT so that's worth seven that I
can go spend wherever I want so I just
created two bitcoins out of thin air so
the idea that this requirement to prove
that things are positive is absolutely
fundamental to preventing spenders from
creating money out of thin air yeah this
is essential even though we ignore we
can have normally we would ignore it
this is kind of a necessary thing to
verify no no there's no the fees are
determined by a how quickly you want
transaction to be processed and also
there are some transactions that happen
to be bigger because they have more
inputs and outputs transactions that are
big if if a minor takes a transaction
that's bigger that means he has less
space in the block - he can only he can
only package fewer transactions in the
block because so you still could be
compensated since the transaction is
like twice as big as a normal
transaction transaction if he has to be
twice as big otherwise the minor
wouldn't want to take it because it
would cost him there would be a cost to
that
so in fact everything that I said before
is correct I mean the transactions are
packaged based on their value modulo the
size as well so there's actually a bit
of a bin packing problem when you when
you decides which transactions to take
yeah okay so this is probably clear so
we have to prove star and we have to
prove other things are positive it turns
out proving linear relations is easy
proving there things are positive is
hard yeah and that's actually where our
work is and so what we did is basically
we have a new system called bulletproof
switch is a way to actually do these
these zero knowledge proof very
efficiently yeah phishing zero knowledge
proof on uncommitted values so you can
prove that about the committed value is
passed
I can tell you that our proof sighs if
you have an end bid range a proof size
is logarithmic in n where previously it
was linear in n so so this new bullet
proof actually is an exponential
improvement on what was known before
which I don't know it's kind of a me
it's a little surprising it can be done
I should say it's built on an earlier
proof systems of boodle at all the more
important thing is in typically in the
blockchain you don't just have one zero
knowledge proof you have many zero
knowledge proof yeah and in fact if you
need to do D range proofs you need to do
prove that D values are positive because
of this logarithmic behavior normally
for it would be the size of the proof
would be D times n for us it's log n
plus log D so you just if you need to do
ten proofs you just add you know three
more elements and you have ten proofs
yeah so this is a big deal this is kind
of very very large savings on size of
the block for the blockchain so let me
show you this concretely how well this
works so here we have kind of if you
need to do one proof one range proof for
the blockchain you know originally the
proof would have been four kilobytes
with us there's six hundred and seventy
two bytes but if you do need to do ten
proofs in other words if you have or two
proofs if you have two outputs before
the proof would just double in size
whereas for us it's just an additive you
just add a little bit one more element
to the proof and everything and you have
two proofs basically similarly if you
needed to do ten proofs if you have a
transaction with ten outputs before it
would become really quite expensive to
include whereas for us for us it's
actually relatively cheap to do I wanted
to mention also there's another
technology for zero knowledge proof
called snarks but that's that actually
has slightly trade-offs a slightly
different trade-offs so I think in the
interest of time I will not talk about
Snorks here okay so that's gonna where
we are so just to conclude I wanted to
tell you that essentially what we're
able to do so we're able to basically
make Bitcoin transactions you know
usable for salaries for supply chain and
things like that and then are basically
because our proofs are so much shorter
we can reduce the blockchain size by
almost a factor of nine so it's a lot of
savings for the miners
reduces costs for everybody basically
what's even more interesting is we have
an older result on proving solvency so
you must have heard of exchanges that
you know said the idea in exchange in
crypto currency exchanges is rather than
people keeping the money at home they
themselves where they could you know
lose them say your house catches fire
and now you lost all your money you give
you you give the proceed to private heat
in exchange like coinbase to manage well
some people gave their secret keys to an
exchange called mouth [ __ ] and that
hasn't turned out so well
yes Mongkok sort of lost all their all
the money that was given to them so we
have this mechanism which is a zero
knowledge proof of solvency where the
exchange can do something that cannot be
done in the physical world you can prove
an exchange can prove that the sum of
its obligations is less than or equal to
the sum of its assets and it can do so
in zero knowledge so it doesn't reveal
what its obligations are and it doesn't
reveal what its assets are yeah so we
can do all that and with these new
bullet proof techniques actually we kind
of get like a 300 X improvement over our
previous protocol so yeah so this seems
to have lots of applications yeah to
various blockchain requirements and
finally I was really happy to see Minero
is one of the privacy mechanisms private
private blockchains and they just they
just announced that they're moving to
bullet proofs so this presumably this
summer will get will get deployed so
it's kind of cool actually it's played
this space like you come up with an idea
and people quickly run with it which is
really really really fun too which is
why it's really fun to work in so again
I encourage everyone you know to work in
the area there's a lot of open problems
lots of fun problems to work on and
people are kind of desperate for ideas
so anything you come up with people
adapt adopt okay
so I'll stop here Thanks and one
[Applause]
thanks why the next thing goes setting
up this time well look in the consensus
space there's still lots of questions
about consensus protocols so this proof
of work consensus or rather mining on
the longest chain right it's problematic
for many many reasons that means if you
have like mining in the longest change
means that if you have a really large
transaction for like a billion dollars
it's quite dangerous to do on the
blockchain because if I could spend the
billion dollars and then I could
actually offer someone a reward to for
up the chain right so that's you know
they lose everything they've gained so
far but they'll gain this this huge
reduction there was a there was this
credit so mine even the longest
blockchain actually is kind of
problematic for large transactions so
what's you know how do we handle that
and that's you again lots of ideas for
how to handle them properly but you know
there's still a lot of need for more for
more there are a lot of problems are on
languages for smart contracts how do you
writes monochrome smart contracts in a
way that we can verify them efficiently
so that's a huge area and you didn't
know Nick it isn't designed like I said
like these mining pools we still don't
have a good answer lots to think about
cool thanks thank you all right
so they speak I need some introduction
professor Ballinger butter on real time
this is